le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
faire garder son enfant est très souvent
un véritable casse-tête pour une grande
partie des familles réunionnaises manque
de place coût trop élevé sont des freins
importants pour pouvoir faire garder son
enfant alors que l'on sait que c'est un
impératif pour permettre de reprendre
son travail ou de trouver une insertion
professionnelle alors existe-t-il des
solutions à ce problème
on en parle maintenant dans léa sociale
pour faire garder son enfant en bas âge
jusqu'à la rentrée à l'école
il n'existe pas beaucoup de solutions il
y a les crèches souvent saturé mais il y
a aussi les assistantes maternelles
cette dernière alternative est pratique
et séduisante pour les enfants ainsi que
pour les mamans qui reprennent le
travail
une assistante maternelle est agréé par
le département égard de votre enfant
chez elles dans des conditions
réglementé est tout à fait optimale pour
le bonheur et la sécurité des jeunes
enfants mais la mise aux normes des
maisons est assez coûteuse selon les cas
et même si le conseil général propose
des aides pour l'aménagement
parfois cela ne suffit pas ou alors il
arrive qu'elle soit mal situer par
rapport aux zones de fréquentation et
donc peu pratique pour les parents
du coup des assistantes maternelles ne
peuvent pas exercer
c'est pour ces raisons que le conseil
général incite à la création de maisons
d'assistantes maternelles avec pour
objectif que les réunionnais puissent
disposer de deux maisons d'assistantes
maternelles par commune
cette solution répond aux besoins de
tous les intéressés car les parents ont
des options supplémentaires pour faire
garder leurs enfants et les assistantes
maternelles peuvent exercer dans de
bonnes conditions
c'est le cas de madame budel qui ne
pouvait pas garder plus de deux enfants
dans sa maison car l'aménagement pour la
mise aux normes étaient trop coûteux
chez moi je travaille à 2 jamais une
maison elle n'était pas assez grand trop
petit pour pouvoir accueillir quatre
enfants jamais pas suffisamment aux
loyers pour les travaux pouvoir
accueillir trois ou quatre fois de plus
avec mes collègues il a décidé de
travailler sur un projet donc une mam
donc aujourd'hui social est ravi
d'autant plus le talent ray pour deux
elle habitait un appartement c'était
très difficile
il ya deux qu'habiter affiche une bombe
dans les eaux avec sa famille s'était
pas au c'était pas possible d'accueillir
4 bat pour les parents c'est une bonne
chose
on est toutes les trois travail et donc
du coup les parents sont beaucoup plus
rassuré il suffit qu'il a une qui tombe
malade mais de l'autre elle est là donc
du coup les parents sont ravis ils sont
vraiment contents de savoir qu'ils
peuvent compter sur une autre toute
l'année mais les enfants à ça les
prépare pour l'école déjà parce que la
petite productivité on a un outil non on
est à 12 entre 12 et 14 par jour dont
les enfants sont vraiment ravis et ça
permet aussi de d'échanger plus
facilement
c'est vraiment un coup de coeur pour ce
métier donc c'est un choix de travailler
avec les enfants mais de la santé
travaillant mam et d'avoir constamment
comme à la maison
c'est ce que j'aime en fait aujourd'hui
je je je m'en réjouis de travailler
ainsi d'accueillir tous les matins ce
petit bout et les voit partir avec le
creusot avec un grand sourire
ac c'est ma joie la maison d'assistantes
maternelles est une initiative soutenue
par le conseil général est une
alternative intéressante pour tous les
acteurs concernés
le fait de pouvoir exercer permet à une
assistante maternelle d'avoir des
revenus mais aussi de mutualiser les
coûts avec ses autres collègues et
d'échanger sur les pratiques
professionnelles
et
ce dispositif est d'une grande
efficacité car il apporte des solutions
aux parents et créer des emplois
il est aussi renforcée par le cheik
marmailles qui soutient financièrement
les parents en offrant une participation
à la garde de leurs enfants
il manque des places dans les crèches
donc nous agrée ont un maximum de
personnes pour être des assistantes
maternelles et nous permettons de payer
plus cher en le chèque marmaille
simplement souvent les maisons des
assistantes maternelles de non pas les
conditions que la loi demande pour être
habilité
donc aujourd'hui nous voulons créer des
maisons des assistantes maternelles pour
que ces assistantes se regroupent elle
est leur formation on les aide
financièrement à payer donc les premiers
les premiers besoins
pour mettre tout cela aux normes avoir
le cadre qu'il faut tout le matériel est
ainsi elles pourront sans difficulté
recevoir des enfants dans de très bonnes
chances pour aider toutes les marques
tous les mamans papas de ville à avoir
une place facilement
nous voulons accompagner de man par par
commune donc pour offrir des bonnes
conditions sécurisées d'accueil pour les
parents afin que quand il laisse les
bambino soit rassuré les trois premières
années de la vie d'un enfant sont très
importantes
il est donc nécessaire de pouvoir lui
offrir des conditions optimales
indispensable à son épanouissement
les assistantes maternelles apporte un
confort et une qualité de vie pour les
enfants en bas âge grâce aux maisons
d'assistants maternels
le conseil général permet aux parents de
pouvoir travailler l'esprit tranquille
et continue de créer des emploi
d'assistante maternelle
une équation parfaite qui contribue
activement à la construction de l'avenir
de là réunion le conseil général de la
réunion vous a présenté lien social le
conseil général aux côtés des
réunionnais